[Music]
during my undergrad college years
for the most part i had a very good time
on campus
i made many strong friendships
but it just never really happened in my
dorm
my dorm was a place where i slept
not the place where i lived
my eagerness and enthusiasm to fit in
were met with mere
politeness there was a kind of
acknowledgement through small talk but
conversations never really progressed
i grew tired of walking into that dorm
feeling like such a stranger
i vividly recall walking through the
hallways of my dorm
on friday and saturday nights i would
hear
music playing a crowd of voices lots of
laughter
and the sound of parties behind closed
doors
at first i was surprised i'd never heard
about this parties happening
and with time i started to feel a bit
sad about it
of course i could have knocked on doors
or asked around but
who wants to invite themselves to a
party
i wanted to feel wanted
the experience taught me that an
invitation
is the highest form of compliment
i've thought about my undergrad dorm
experience for years
about the power of our mundane
interactions with one another
about the difference between being
polite and being present
about the difference between tolerance
and belonging
about the power and responsibility we
all share
to make wherever we live work and play
a more genuinely inclusive experience
for all of us
i've realized that invitations are
important but it's only part of it
for more clues i started to think of
times when i did feel a sense of
belonging in college and funny enough
every moment that came to mind had a
common denominator
my friend bright
yes his name is actually bright as in
bright light bright is from ghana
he immigrated to the us when he was 10
years old and developed a
strong interest in history maybe that's
why he also developed a genuine interest
in people which enables him to live up
to his name
bright is someone who has countless
times exemplified behaviors that create
belonging
after reflecting on how bright interacts
with people
i've learned four major lessons which i
want to share with you
with them i hope we can all make sure
that no one in our surroundings
ever feels the way i did in my undergrad
dorm
i call these lessons the right way
to foster belonging number one
as i've shared make invitations
they're the highest form of compliment
but there's more
number two make enthusiastic
introductions
bright never misses the opportunity to
introduce people to each other
and the most exciting way possible
i was once walking on campus and
inadvertently heard someone
scream my name hey jp
of course it was bright staining about
250 feet away from me
that's almost the length of a football
field
he was working with jerry and wanted to
make sure he introduced us to each other
when he finally reached me wright said
jp you have to meet jerry she's really
the coolest person here
he distilled and relayed the best parts
of her personalities
and accomplishments to each other he
made us feel
special he made us feel appreciated and
he made us feel
valued bright's glowing introduction
led to jerry and i building a strong
friendship still flourishing today
nine years later number three
make it a habit to reach out from those
who are closest to you
to those you don't see as often
for example bright's roommate was andy
andy was much more reserved than bright
but still
wright was always the first to remember
reaching out to andy
to check in on him and invite him to
things
i would hear him say things like hey
andy do you want to join us for dinner
andy i haven't seen you all day is
everything all right you wanna come and
study with us
he made a point to notice not only who
is present
but also who is absent understandably
we may sometimes hesitate on reaching
out to certain people for
fear of sounding too pushy
but bright's way is unique because for
him
the fear of a friend feeling excluded
always supersedes to fear of what others
might think of him
checking on those who may seem
extroverted as well
i remember a friend who i thought was
doing well as she was always surrounded
by people
after her second year she transferred
schools and it turns out she was not
doing so well
it turns out she did not feel a sense of
belonging in our community
i wish i'd reached out now i know
now you know
number four when you do reach out
really make time to connect
wright was affectionately called uncle
bright
by many of our friends because he made
time for them he made it clear he was
ready and willing to listen
he stopped what he was doing he made eye
contact
listen when you spoke did not interrupt
and asked questions
and he didn't do it with just people in
his close circle he did this with
everyone for example
i remember going to one of our dining
halls we're always greeted by john
on the kitchen staff john never failed
to shout bride's name hey bright so good
to see you
because bright will do the same hey john
how are you
so good to see you too
you see bright was not simply respectful
of those who supported us like
library staff dining hall workers and
maintenance crews in fact
that should be expected of everyone what
he did differently was
actually taking the time to get to know
people and have a genuine conversation
with everyone he came across
of course not everyone is as extroverted
as bright
it can also be toxic to always engage as
enthusiastically as he does especially
if he doesn't come second nature to us
the goal here is really to engage in
these behaviors as often as we can
without depleting ourselves for example
as an introvert
i found ways to adapt to lessons i've
learned from pride
in ways that i can digest
here's how i apply these principles and
of course i'm still working on doing
better
i consistently look for opportunities to
make invitations
and i try to make them personal and
intentional
for example instead of making a general
dinner invitation to a large group
i would prefer reaching out to each
person individually and let them know i
would love it
if they could be there the signal i hope
to send
is that i appreciate them and would love
to share my time
my most valuable asset with them
i do my best to check in on close
friends from time to time and put in an
extra effort to reach out to those i've
not heard from in a while
and when i do reach out to people
sometimes the interaction can last an
hour
or it could be just five minutes what
really matters
is to be present and intentional
so whether it has extroverted as bright
or more introverted like me remember
make invitations make enthusiastic
introductions
make it a habit to reach out from those
you're closest to to those you don't see
as often
and when you do reach out really make
time
to connect
and if you find yourself
secluded with no one
expressing belonging behaviors towards
you
i encourage you to seek to be the friend
you wish you had to others
you'll not only benefit but others will
be
grateful to you be brave
and be bright